le président 2015 toutes les ressources
que nous consommons ne sont plus là en
alors qu'est ce que ce sera en 2050
lorsque nous serons 10 milliards 10
milliards de bouches à nourrir
sachant qu'aujourd'hui déjà une personne
sur neuf ne mange pas à sa faim
c'est à dire 600 millions de personnes
qu'est ce que ce sera en 2050 2050 c'est
dans 35 ans c'est nos enfants c'est leur
enfant et c'est nous alors il ya ceux
qui ne mangent pas assez mais il ya
aussi ceux qui ne mangent pas bien la
moitié des personnes des pays ocde dont
nous sont en surpoids
sans parler des carences en fer et en
protéines qui touche notamment les
femmes les personnes âgées et les
enfants
et justement les protéines nous serons
10 milliards à en avoir besoin
en 2050 mais les protéines aujourd'hui
c'est 50 % de la pollution mondiale
l'élevage c'est la moitié de la
pollution mondiale devant les transports
et cette consommation et chaque année en
augmentation mais qui en profite
et bien si tout le monde devait manger
comme nous ces quatre planètes qu'il
nous faudrait aujourd'hui pour vivre
comme un français donc quelque part si
nous vivons bien c'est grâce à ceux qui
ne mangent pas et grâce au fait que
l'afrique à l entière ne participe qu'à
3 % de la pollution mondiale
alors on regardait ces chiffres avec ma
cousine qui on est très gourmande
alors on se demander quand même est-ce
que manger c'est forcément pollué et
quand on avait cette discussion
moi j'étais en chine je regardais sur
les marchés qu'est ce qu'on mange
ailleurs et quelles protéines on mange
ailleurs eh bien figurez vous
qu'on ne mange pas que de la viande et
j'ai découvert que ce que l'on mange est
là bas entre autres 80% de la population
mondiale en mangeaient aussi et en
raffolait sous toutes ses formes
les insectes finalement on est une
petite minorité à ne pas en manger mais
alors on s'est renseigné pourquoi tous
ces humains mange des insectes
parce que c'est bon pour la santé
je vous le confirme on en mange tous les
jours maintenant
donc c'est bon pour la santé tout
d'abord parce que c'est très riche en
protéines on en parle beaucoup et c'est
vrai que c'est plus riche que la viande
rouge de la viande blanche
c'est très riche en fer en fer
assimilables faut savoir que le faire
végétal est malheureusement moins
assimilables que le faire animal et le
fer contenu dans les insectes est
nettement supérieur au fer qu'il ya dans
la viande
mais ce n'est pas tout il ya aussi
beaucoup de nutriments il ya des oméga-3
et très peu dassier devra penser de la
viande plus saine en somme c'est pas
tout
c'est très bon pour l'environnement donc
comme julia vous a dit ça représente 50
% de la pollution mondiale déjà parce
que ça nécessite énormément d'eau
ces quinze mille litres d'eau pour un
steak de boeuf
ça fait beaucoup l'eau les insectes qui
respire par le ventre donc en fait ne
peuvent pas avoir accès directement à
l'eau il les hydrates uniquement avec le
jus des fruits des légumes ça fait moins
d'eau pour la nourriture ils ont besoin
de très peu de nourriture car elle
nécessite que deux semaines d'élevage
contre un boeuf de trois à cinq ans ils
émettent forcément beaucoup beaucoup
moins de co2 et nécessite très peu
d'espacé parce que vous voulez les
élever à la verticale face à tout ça on
s'est dit c'est pas possible à falloir
trouver une solution puis avant on s'est
demandé quand même est-ce que l'insecte
aurait sa place dans nos assiettes
est-ce qu'il a sa place chez
jean s'est rendu compte de deux choses
d'abord qu'autrefois
l'insecte faisait partie du patrimoine
gastronomique de la france une certaine
conteste en offrait à ses invités pour
les remercier des festivités choses ont
bien changé et deuxième chose c'est
qu'il ya eu plein de révolution
alimentaire sans s'en rendre compte en
france partout dans le monde
par exemple le homard le homard ça vous
étonne envir moi aussi eh bien
figurez-vous qu'en californie les
prisonniers faisait des émeutes contre
ceux qui osent et leur faut leur donner
du homard à midi mais c'est aussi le cas
de la pomme de terre le cas de la tomate
le cas du sushi peut-être que certains
d'entre vous mangent ces aliments
aujourd'hui en tout cas ça a mis
beaucoup de temps beaucoup de politiques
publiques et entreprenariale pour que
les gens acceptent d'en manger et
maintenant au quotidien donc on s'est
dit on s'est demandé avec sarah est ce
qu'on va attendre pour quelles raisons
puisqu'aujourd'hui on peut choisir et
aujourd'hui on a cette chance notamment
d'avoir énormément d'informations qui
nous donne l'opportunité de faire un
choix éclairé
donc pourquoi pas l'insecte donc notre
mission vous l'aurez compris cette
démocratiser l'insecte en occitan mais
alors pour cela il fallait trouver des
stratégies astucieuse on s'est dit qu'il
fallait le rendre invisible donc on l'a
mixé nos insectes
on les a transformés en farine et on les
a intégrés à un produit connu un produit
rassurant un produit qui pouvaient
délicieux et qu'ils pouvaient avoir des
valeurs nutritionnelles exceptionnelles
alors délicieux pourquoi parce que les
moeurs
nous sommes intimement persuadés
qu'elles vont changer dans le plaisir
la douceur et la facilité et du coup on
se positionne comme des accompagnants
donc ces barques vous avons fait
elles sont délicieuses peut-être que
vous pourrez voir
elles ont quatre goût pour le moment
pistache chocolat la verte la orange
abri cottin fèves de cacao cru la jaune
et gingembre fig
lafleur on a élaboré ses recettes avec
des nutritionnistes et des ingénieurs
agroalimentaires dans l'objectif de
faire une barre dont délicieuse mais
surtout très bonne pour la santé parce
qu'on voulait allier le discours envoie
environnementale certes mais surtout le
discours nutritionnels c'est à dire
faire prendre conscience à quel point
c'est important ce qu'on mange
et donc pour cela les bars que nous
avons fait
elle contient énormément de protéines
vous imaginez bien énormément de faire
énormément de fibres pas de sucre
raffiné et pas de matière grasse l'idée
c'est d'avoir un snack complet et que
vous mangiez en vous disant là je me
fait du bien
là je suis super content parce que tout
est en ordre
mais papy ma tête mon corps mais ce
n'est pas tout parce que pour que tout
cela rentre dans les moeurs
il va bien falloir faire d'autres
produits alors aujourd'hui l'insecte cd
barre mais demain lorsque vous ouvrirez
le frigo vous hésiterez entre cuisse de
poulet avec saumon une salade d'algues
un steak de tofu et pourquoi pas une
fricassée de sauterelles aux champignons
alors rejoignez nous dans cette
révolution révolution du tri sionnel
puisque l'insecte pourra répondre aux
carences qu'on a évoqué
environnementales puisqu'il sera interne
hâtive à la viande et aux poissons
gastronomique parce qu'on va se régaler
et économique car c'est toute une
filière en occident qui est à bâtir